welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus Docker on this episode I
talk with Vincent boulanin Vincent is a
senior researcher at the Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
and there he spent several years
researching the combination of
artificial intelligence and nuclear
weapon systems in this podcast we talk
about his findings we talk about the key
lessons that we should take for how to
do this safely and we talk about several
specific policy measures that might
reduce nuclear risk here is Vincent
bulani
Vincent welcome to the podcast
hello and thanks for having me again
fantastic you have a system for
categorizing the risks posed by
artificial intelligence and nuclear
weapons and this system consists of
concentric circles maybe you could
explain how you categorize these risks
thanks
um so yes as part of our work we
[Music]
we thought that it would be kind of
helpful to add to kind of distinguish
the risk based on bitback what is the
source and nature of the the kind of the
core problem
and we found that there's the kind of
different layers and as you said like so
we have these different concentric
Circle and let's say like the base one
like the the broadest one
uh is the fact that we are talking about
um a technology that has inner technical
techno technical limitations so the
extent of the problems are related to
how AI actually works or doesn't work
and these are the like the fundamental
problems so they include the things
related to uh when you have machine
learning systems that is the so-called
Black Box problem the ice is related to
the opacity of algorithm
um which might in turn lead to kind of
promote predictability of behavior when
we are talking about for instance kind
of
on body system like autonomous robots
and so on what is the the black box
problem for example what do you mean by
opacity of the machine learning systems
I'll try to kind of give a a known
expert answer given I'm not an actual
kind of AI technician
um or researcher but the the basic
problem is that when for certain type of
of um of machine learning methods uh
including methods like deep learning the
process is such that you train up the
system to do something and you know what
data the input of the system you know
the output but you don't necessarily
know what's happening in between so the
system learns to do something to
recognize I don't know a cat based on a
millions of pictures of cats that you
provide to the system label pictures
and the stimulant to kind of identify
elements on the picture table you know
to recognize a cat but you don't
necessarily know exactly how
the system is making this different
connections and making this statistical
relationship between different data
points so you know that the system may
be recognizing cat at 99
accuracy but you don't necessarily know
what are the criteria used so it can
program to can lead to problem of um
predictability and reliability because
if you are using
we're releasing your cat by your tank
and if you train your system by
recognizing tanks by using a lot of
pictures of tanks you know a classic
example that people gave is that there's
the risk for instance that the system
recognize things by just identifying
elements related to the green color or
green background like a lot of pictures
that you have might be like oh these are
things in the forest so if there's a
tree then it means that probability to
track is high and so and the fact that
we don't necess we don't have really
good methods to understand how the
system learned can be a problem in the
context of military use of AI so I know
that there's a lot of research ongoing
to try to kind of solve that issue which
create kind of you know safety problems
and security problems and so on but
that's one of the you know one of the
technical challenges to recent advances
of oh they are in the in the spring when
we talk basically about machine learning
so that's the biggest concentric Circle
containing the inherent problems with
artificial intelligence and machine
Learning Systems within that Circle you
then have the combination of military
applications with AI
yeah so so basically all the problems I
just mentioned do not disappear but then
then it's important to kind of move into
things that are related to kind of the
impact that AI have on the military
sphere
so basically how AI is kind of like
impacting notably
um the way we develop
um military system uh but also how it's
affecting military practice and
especially military decision making
and so in the previous podcast we
mentioned a few some of the problems or
the fact that then AI is a kind of
intangible technology makes in the
military domain that's potentially
problematic because it makes it harder
for for
one country to identify the capabilities
of the other country in turn also during
the conflict if you know it's if you are
the one deploying A system that you
might have problems with the prom with
this thing called signaling so signaling
your intentions and capability can also
be harder or it's more easily that the
other side might misunderstand
your intentions or your actual
capabilities and react in a
disproportionate way
so this kind of like this kind of
strategy kind of calculus make armored
order but to some extent and another
um issue is the fact that as AI is
enabling more automation of military
decision making and some type of
processes
the fact that the potentially increase
the speed of warfare that allows people
I mean states to kind of fight have
machine speed but then it kind of has an
impact on Military decision making where
the decision making time is reduced
potentially like there's a erosion of
human judgment or like of human control
over some critical decisions and that
can lead to kind of different type of
like security like strategic problems
but also things related to Modern Realms
of ethics and weather like if
undermined people's ability to kind of
comply with the law and so on how does
this problem play out is it the case
that the speed of military action is
increased if you have two militaries
both using AI technology to fight each
other or is the pace or the speed of
warfare also increased if you have one
military using more conventional method
methods and one military using AI to in
the in a military context
so of the two cases that you mentioned
obviously the first one is the is the
more extreme one where
this is kind of the race to the bottom
in terms of where if both states have
the impression that speed is the kind of
the critical element for having a
strategic advantage or competitive
advantage over your enemy then you have
this that Dynamic wire
the the both sides are incentivized to
maybe automate more
um and that speed up to kind of like to
speed up the decision making time to
have to prove to gain pressure seconds
or minutes over over the enemy and
that's where potentially that can lead
to
to in some cases two problem if uh
because it makes maybe the interaction
between human machines more more
sensitive uh it might increase the risk
of accidents inadvertent escalation
based on like you know a prime of like
judgment in time critical situation and
so
yeah what about this problem of AI
technology being
kind of stolen by non-state actors so
what I'm what I'm thinking about here is
maybe terrorists could get accents
access to drones that are that contain
highly capable AI technology
so uh thing so that's definitely um
another set of risks that you may put
into this second layer of the kind of AI
police military risk and one is
I mean it's not a new problem the fact
that some technologies are being
diverted and is used by malicious actors
like terrorist groups or Rock States
it's not new I mean we have seen the
case already with with drones and you
don't even need to kind of put the eye
in them like just remotely controlled
drones where I think the challenge in
the case of AI and Robotics in general
is that we are talking about weapon like
technology that highly dual use in
nature
um where the the need what what is
needed to kind of weaponize or
technology might not be
so technically technologically
complicated or difficult
um and the fact that a lot of like
commercial Technologies are actually
pretty good and it doesn't you wouldn't
require much from uh from an actor
especially after that does not care so
much about safety and performance to
kind of just take a commercial
technology weaponize it
in ways that would be you know
potentially destructive so and we have
seen cases in the past where
Hobbies drones like recreational drones
that the ones that you can buy uh on
Amazon I've been used in the conflict in
Ukraine I've been used in Syria to uh
basically as as flying kind of uh ID so
it improvised direct explosive device
um or basically that they take the Drone
and mount uh a Grenade on it and just
just fly to a destination to kind of
bomb a military base or whatever
um so we have seen that in the past so
there's there is that it can also be the
case with some other type of AI
technologies that these commercial
sections can be misuse is is a real
problem
um and in a way it's already it's
already the journey is somehow already
out of the bottle
um and is that because these AI
Technologies are open source they're
available on the internet to be
incorporated in various applications or
in what senses the genie already out of
the bottle I mean it's partly this one
that that one dimension there's the fact
that a lot of
the Baseline kind of technology that you
need like you said a lot of algorithm
are open source or easily accessible on
the internet a lot of databases are open
source or like easy to access but you
can train your system to recognize
things and objects and so on
so that's one dimension of the problem
um the openness of the aim and another
problem is the fact that the the
knowledge
to develop AIC send is fairly widely
distributed so if you compare to nuclear
technology nuclear power technology like
the
it's
there's not as many kind of um like
people that have the know-how to kind of
turn civilian nuclear uh technology into
like and make a nuclear bomb out of it
so it Demands a various kind of like
Niche skill set and also like financial
resources and so on but this domain in
terms of like scales and financial
resources are much lower when you talk
about the iso and when I say that region
is out of the bottle is that we have
seen already cases where some civilian
developments have been weaponized in
ways that are disruptive so
I'm thinking for example of the case of
um deep fake so the misuse of generative
address neural network so
um our kind of AI development that allow
AI to kind of create new content like a
new uh you know that can develop develop
new photos or add pictures based on
existing photos and pictures uh that can
be that has already been used for this
information purposes
um
for instance so it's kind of very
concrete case of the fact that some
civilian Technologies people that
developed that had no intentions to kind
of do harm but some other people might
find ways to kind of misuse that so then
the question is how do you mitigate
potentially that risk in an effective
way we have the biggest concentric
Circle which is just the problems
inherent with AI within that Circle we
have the problems that arise when we
combine AI with military applications
and within that Circle we then have the
combination of AI and nuclear systems so
the nuclear systems the problems with
combining AI with nuclear systems
this problem it contains everything from
the from the broader circles so uh to
solve the the problem of combining AI
with nuclear we have to solve all of the
problems we just talk through in
addition to some problems that that we
can discuss now which is which problems
are speci arise specifically when we try
to combine AI with nuclear technology
thanks so basically these are the kind
of like the nuclear weapon specific
problem and in a way they are not new uh
this problem exists before with other
Technologies as well uh AI is just
reinforcing them
potentially also changing their nature
uh but basically these relate to the
fact that AI the progress of AI might
have an impact on States uh see their
ability to retaliate
um against the Nico first strike
and so basically you know how confident
they are in their deterrent architecture
returns architecture
um and basically the impact would be
threefold so a we could see a dynamic
where there's a kind of instability
created by the fact that the engagements
or follow arms race Behavior where they
try to kind of match each other's
capability in the field of AI or respond
to okay let's one state is is advancing
on uh on the ID of this field that can
feel it not able to compete so it's
maybe balancing that offset in that with
other
um you know Weaponry development so like
in terms of like maybe adopting uh more
nuclear weapons or modernizing the the
nuclear Arsenal that's one option the
other option is that also like he would
um and critical question it would
increase nuclear risk in two ways a
um the development of deployment of our
in some nuclear
um related systems like Commander
control and early warning and some could
potentially increase the risk of
accident uh accidental escalation
um or inadvertent escalation and we
talked about it in a previous podcast
where either the system is failing and
you know leading people to take the
wrong decision and no don't strike or
that he could like
people might misunderstand or
misinterpret the situation also take the
wrong decision and
um
and the final option is that it also
like increase what we call like the
first striking stability where
if states are
less confident in the ability to
retaliate they might be incentivized to
act quickly and launch the first strike
to prevent it
um on that would basically like you know
basically a threshold to go to the
nuclear level could be reduced
all right so you've been researching the
problem of combining nuclear weapons
with artificial intelligence for a
number of years and you've come up with
some lessons that uh that the world
should incorporate to make ours to make
ourselves uh more safe basically
the first of these lessons is that a
human should remain in the loop what
does what does this mean and how do you
how do you make sure a human remains in
the loop
yeah so maybe just to kind of say a
couple of words of intro so one of um we
we find lessons from the past
mainly because like automation which is
one of the key feature of of AI is is
not fundamentally new in the context of
of the nuclear details architecture a
lot of things
have been automated the states have been
a new clamps have been relying on
computer and algorithm for a long time
and one of the lessons from the past is
that it's good to you to keep human in
the loop
um because systems might not be on the
person reliable and there might be cases
where
human's ability to how to use some kind
of common common sense will be you know
critical and to keep human as a kind of
a failsafe mechanism is essential
um we have seen cases in the past like
the famous one is the 1983 page of
incident
um or basically this this uh the
commander profile was in charge of
supervising the early warning and system
of the Soviet Union was able to kind of
I understand that when the system
detected that the US was launching a
strike against Soviet Union he
understood that something because he
knew the system was not highly reliable
any kind of understood okay there must
be a technical glitch hunting is this
doesn't make sense and he decided not to
be brought up the incident and that
basically prevented the Third
you know nuclear
um yeah third world war and nuclear use
and nuclear weapons the use of nuclear
weapons so with that the key lesson from
there is that it's good to kind of keep
a human in the loop to keep also the
early warning system separate from your
new camera control and that Germans are
like kind of it's air gap and the human
is in the middle
mainly to do one thing to interpret the
information and try to kind of
um and then actually like engage in the
decision of authorizing the nuclear
weapon notes so that it's so it's not
you don't automate that process fully so
the system detects something and then
does that make sense makes perfect sense
yeah could we imagine a situation in
which artificial intelligence gets so
Advanced that keeping a human in the
loop would actually make make the system
less safe so if we take the example of
autonomous cars for example I assume
that at some point autonomous cars will
get so good that keeping a human driver
in the driving seat will will make the
car less safe it does a similar Point
hold for for nuclear launch systems or
are we just so far away from that point
that it doesn't really make sense to
talk this way
I mean it's it's a difficult question I
would I would argue that it's
there's a the technical argument of like
you know weapons I mean systems
technologies are become more reliable
than humans
that could be that's a point that could
be meant that but it doesn't mean that
you you need to remove humans from the
decision-making Loop and you can have
both you can have a system that is
really that is really good at detecting
things and providing information but
but given that we are actually talking
about you know the use of nuclear weapon
systems just like you could also make
just the ethical argument that it's it
should humans should be the ones like
making the final call like even if the
systems are really good at making
assessment and detecting things
in most cases also because you have you
will you will have the time to make some
decision it's not like it's you need to
make a Split Second
decision and therefore you need to
automate fully like
it's it makes sense to kind of keep
humans as the kind of the ultimate kind
of
um decision maker so it's not just a
technical Point there's also an ethical
point in keeping humans in the loop
yeah I mean I think it and it's it's
something that came out clearly from the
research that we did and when we engage
with different expert that
in general like it's if there's one
decision that is hyped like extremely
political is the the decision to kind of
use the nuclear weapons there's
clear clear processes that have been
established by by States and general
they will involve like you know
petitions has to be made by the highest
level of command usually like the head
of state uh involving other people that
also can
kind of balance that decision so you
don't have just one person making
deciding everything like someone else
also tries to win
so yeah it's it it's the highly and
highly political process and
you wouldn't
know it seems like most States would
agree that it wouldn't make sense to
automate that
yeah so the first lesson is that we
should keep humans in the loop and the
other side of that coin is then that
keeping humans in the loop won't solve
all our problems human supervision is
not a Panacea as you write
um why is this the case so
I think the the argument is to say that
it's also just mindful to kind of
so you're looking back at the past like
a lot of
incidents happen from the interaction
between the human and the automated
system
and so having your human supervising the
system might not just might not be
enough in itself I mean it's important
to kind of Bear in mind that a lot of
problem can happen from the you know the
interaction and its our systems become
more complex it can be challenging for
humans to kind of
mounting meaningful human control or
supervision over the system to be
actually able to understand
what the system is doing
um and it's a problem that
is well known from the
um you know Aerospace industry when
commercial left lights like when they
have been incident with commercial
aircraft it's because like something
like the system the automatic system
kind of reported a problem and the human
was not able to kind of meaningfully
understand what the problem was and
interact you know in a
in a way that would prevent prevent an
accident
um and we have seen also that case in
the military context what there have
been some systems in the missile defense
or like there are different systems that
that are
where there was some incident because
like the humans either kind of over
trusted or under trusted the system and
that led to a different type of uh
harmfulness like a famous example is the
the factory side during the second Gulf
War in 2003 where the the U.S Petro
system was involved in two uh 40 side
incidents
um and part of these incidents were
caused by by the interaction between the
the operator and the system
and basically the bottom line from there
is that to avoid that
problem uh it's important to kind of add
a technical level to kind of really
invest in ensuring the reliability of
the system and testing them so having
proper kind of testing and valuation
processes that would also give a a good
picture of like how reliable the system
can be and what are the limitations
it's also important to test like the
human machine interaction in a sense so
ensure that a the design allowed the
user to kind of
understand the system well and but also
yeah you test that interaction so you
can have a feedback loop while you're
working okay these are problems that
could emerge in your crisis situation
and we'll try to kind of adapt that
either design stage or through training
and that's the final the kind of
recommendation it's very critical to
kind of ensure that the people that are
supposed to supervise these kind of high
stake systems are properly trained that
they understand the system how
physically it works what the problem can
be and so that the
when the time comes and it's a Time
critical situation they will be better
equipped to to use it properly and that
would reduce the risk of incident and
accident so how do we train people to
use these systems and what is it that
we're trying to avoid which biases uh in
the interaction between the systems and
the human are we trying to avoid here
um so I guess the general idea is that
it's not to kind of train people in like
becoming engineers and understand all
the aspects of how the system works but
the system should have sufficient
understanding of
what is the the Baseline of like how
this weather system is brokenizing not
recognizing what other limitations in
terms of like
standard of accuracy precisions and so
on
um so having some basic understanding of
of the systems being provided with that
require also providing some information
about how the system works to the people
that will use them and and they can be
trained in actual like in computer
simulation or personal training like um
where they will get you know some
practice
um
and the the basic problems that these
training are meant to solve like there
are three a um
the kind of these are classic problem of
human machine interaction the first one
is uh automation bias where basically
system people might over trust the
system and might take the information
from the system like you know
uncritically let's say I'm just saying
okay the system is usually good so it
should be right and I'm not I'm not
going to reevaluate or like try to
question that that input do we know why
do we know why humans uh fall victim to
automation bias why is it that we over
trust these systems that we're
interacting with it's I guess it's a
natural process I think we will do that
when we assume that system is working
well
um you know we just create that
confidence that you know should be fine
usually it's fine
um so but in some cases they you know
when it takes a high like it's important
to kind of try to keep a critical
knowledge and and try to kind of see
whether there's maybe other information
that can be compared with so that two
to make sure that the information
progress is actually correct
um the second problem that we identifies
is um
is on the trust when it's the opposite
when actual people don't trust the
system enough
trigger another type of of uh concern
where
people might take different decisions
than the ones who just by the system and
this this should smell so bad might be
hidden fold
so it's about
yeah
data training is useful in terms of like
finding a balance between these kind of
two two hands of the spectrum right
either over trusting or not trusting
enough
um and the final issue is
is to what we call the out of the loop
problem so how to ensure that when
people are not actively supervising the
system and suddenly need to supervise it
and in a Time critical situation that
they are able to kind of regain
sufficient situational awareness
uh you use the car example before so
it's basically like if you have a
self-driving car is driving everything
is fine you're not you don't you're not
looking at the road and suddenly your
system tells you okay now you have to
take back control and you have like you
know 30 seconds because otherwise it's
gonna we're gonna crash so that that's
that's a very difficult situation where
suddenly like someone which like totally
up there I don't know watching a movie
like Harry Potter sudden is to kind of
like take back the wheel can be critical
it can be very difficult so how do you
avoid that or mitigate that problem in
the context of weapon system so to
ensure that when people need to take
back control they will actually be able
to fft take back control or and if they
cannot what other type of fail safe
mechanism do you need to put in place
prevent that type of to prevent accident
basically and we can we can see how this
would be very difficult and increasingly
difficult also as systems become more
and more capable the times in which you
need to intervene in the systems that
they so longer and longer time passes
between when you need to intervene in
the system and so maybe you get
complacent about
intervening and you can imagine that if
you've been sitting and supervising a
system for a month for example where
everything has been working smoothly and
then suddenly you need to intervene
you're not in the right gear to do so
and I'm just saying I'm just trying to
put myself in the place of an operator
of such a system and thinking how hard
it would be to to quickly react to the
system failing where the system has been
working perfectly for a long time
no it's it's an actual personal problem
when I think the military is General
know that problem pretty well and I've
been trying to kind of
they have done a lot of research on it
and trying to kind of find actual
practical ways to kind of mitigate it
but it's not it's not an easy problem
like
yeah which uh which ways could we
mitigate that problem
that would tickle back to
um a the is the training aspect so
ensuring that people are trying to kind
of to be able to have
to respond in that type of situation
there there are clear protocols to
follow and that these kind of like basic
whether they are properly internalized
and so on
there's also a lot of research has been
done in terms of kind of like improving
human machine interfaces so that also
like the way the system is going to
communicate information to the user is
will also be critical
um so basically like if you have a lot
of things like linking and and red light
and sound like you know that might be
overwhelming for the for the people that
needs to make the decision so
um so yeah so this is type of like these
actual practical things that can be done
on a technical level
and finally
um
yeah there's also the the fact of
programming some type of Fail-Safe
mechanism in case uh
um it might be very difficult for the
for the people to kind of regain a
situation awareness and the fight of
like um
search yourself can also be that the
system does not take a critical decision
and
I mean now we're talking a bit in the
app so I could very much depend on what
would be the actual use case what actual
platform we'll be talking about because
then the stakes will be different
um but these are just general lessons
okay so we have the first lesson which
is that people should remain in the loop
humans should remain in the loop the
second lesson which is that uh humans
need to be trained to interact with uh
with nuclear system nuclear weapon
systems and the third lesson is then
that
um we should not make nuclear launch
decisions decisions based on a single
source of information maybe we can talk
about why it's important to have
multiple sources of information here
yeah so um
the lesson here is that also based on
passage in it like it's some of the
incidents that we talked about like the
Petrov incident where that was you know
that one single
uh sources that provided the information
um and basically the the lesson from
that it's useful to have different
different sources of uh of information
to be able to kind of cross check and
check that actually the
um this is reliable information
um and we're not even talking about AI
here I think it's respect to general
practice and it's good to kind of to
cross to cross the different intelligent
sources to kind of verify the
information to to have sent so I think
that's that's General good practice for
any type of
um targeting decision and especially
when when um we talk about nuclear
weapons where the sticks are so high
that you know it's it's Mission critical
that you try to kind of verify uh the
information provided by the Audi warning
system that might include also trying to
verify with some form of verified with
human intelligence
if time allows which hopefully in many
cases did uh it should provide
um you should have time for having
people to kind of look into things
yeah so so which which different
information sources can you use here I'm
imagining that say you're looking at an
at a an AI system that's giving
information about whether a nuclear
launch has happened against the country
um took against the country that that
you are in and if you then try to cross
check that information with other
information wouldn't the other
information sources be far too slow to
be able to create this scenario in which
you have multiple sources of information
and with which sources what would be the
sources of information in this scenario
so thanks I think you thanks for the
question because I think it's good to
own packet
um so I guess when we say about the AI
system detecting things most likely like
I mean it's we will talk basically about
early warning system or uh the physical
detection system and the key element of
that is you need sensors so you need
that would collect information and then
the AI might help
in the detection part trying to kind of
better kind of detect things and
recognize objects or like
and that for that you need one way to
diversify is to have different type of
sensors
so you can have used satellite imageries
all the type of like um ground radar and
and then you cross this different type
of like data sources and AI is maybe
helping this
um different kind of like
sensors with with kind of more kind of
perceptual intelligence where you might
expect AI will allow the systems to be
more accurate in its detection
capabilities so that's one way of doing
it so you diversify the sources and try
to kind of crush it but they will
indicate the same type of information
another way
something that came up in the expect
discussion that we had with uh was that
if states are to rely on machine
Learning System I discussed before the
reliability problem the fact that you
might not sorry kind of
understand how this stem is is actually
working and that might create kind of
you know a sentence here as to whether
the system is actually like so accurate
uh one argument has been mentioned is
that it could be um useful to also rely
on systems that are trained on different
data sets
um so you have like you have diversity
and some form of redundancy in the kind
of like algorithmic kind of like base in
a sense where that would that could give
some some
confirmation that the system is
providing reliable information if you
know that the systems are working a bit
differently
they have been trained on different
assets but they all show the same result
then that if I should give some
confidence that information needs to be
structured trusted it's a form of
redundancy or a form of Sanity check
where say you have four different
machine Learning Systems trained on
different data sets uh using different
information sources and then maybe you
also have corroborating evidence from
from the human investigation well then
you can be much more confident that you
have the the right actionable
information
um in in such a scenario all right
um so I'm guessing what the conclusion
is here you also have what you call a
precaution for the future which is that
we should think about the pros and how
in which situations we should think
about in which situations machine
learning systems work well and in which
situations they they do not work well
um what's the general takeaway here
I guess the general takeaway is that
we know that machine learning is is
enabling the develop of more
potentially more powerful AI systems now
better at recognizing things at
processing different type of information
and so on so there will be in there is a
technical incentive to to adopt the
advances of machine learning also in the
context of nuclear the nuclear weapon
architecture
even if generally speaking states are
very conservative with the adoption of
new technologies when it comes to kind
of the the nuclear deterrence
architecture
um for reasons now related to kind of
Safety and Security and the fact that
it's we are talking about nuclear
weapons
so they want to make sure that the
technology is going to deploy can be
trusted so I guess the the challenge
here like the is that another lessons
for the future is that if states are to
kind of like
to adopt machine learning algorithm in
this context that they should add very
carefully
because problems would likely come from
an immature adoption of the technology
where if they are to adopt technologies
that is not properly tested
uh or the people that use these things
you have not been properly trained to
what
um you know how the systems works or not
they might fail and so on that these
could lead to kind of the kind of the
risk that we talked about before
um so it means that if if like practical
things that would be needed would be
that they invest in significantly in in
testing and evaluation that they'll try
to kind of
notably to kind of develop more kind of
explainable AI uh but also like they
also take into consideration kind of
cyber security risk assit with AI
systems
um
also interest rate that they poisoning
and so on so the number of like actual
things that they will need to kind of
invest to ensure that if they are to
adopt these Technologies this this is
done in a responsible way
let's talk about some specific policy
measures that we could Implement to
lower the risks from combining AI with
nuclear weapons first one is is this a
issue of a no first use policy and this
has been implemented by some countries
and what is it why is it that such a
policy would make us more safe yeah so
perhaps just as a to to take a step back
um
in terms of like concrete measures like
one there's already like existing ways
to address the nuclear risk and
there is what you may say like in the
arms control toolbox that has been
developed during the Cold War people
often think of treaties and things like
that or but there are other things that
can be done at the uni natural level
also bilateral and multilateral level
and one of them is to kind of engage in
in confidence building kind of measures
or things that will give some
diabetes in the effect because by and
and
and these measures or these type of
measures have existing for a long time
and some of them are highly relevant in
the context of
of of AI nuclear risk
um you just mentioned like the first one
is to kind of adopt the Northwest use
policy
um two states already have one uh that
adopted that police unitarily like China
and India
I will spell you the details but it's
largely connected to kind of like their
the Geo strategic context in which they
are in
um but it has argue it has a stabilizing
effect because if um
if States I've said that they will know
they will not use
um they will not conduct a premium
strike that that should give the
confidence to the others that that they
should not be too worried
um but then there's the question of
whether that whether it's politically
conceivable feasible for other states to
also adopt a similar policy when we talk
to expert a web they were pretty
pessimistic about the possibility that
um the U.S or Russia would also adopt
the no first use
why I would argue most likely because of
the fact that they believe that their
nuclear Doctrine as we say
um has been an effective deterrent
basically
um and they would they don't think that
they would I mean they could even argue
that that would actually undermine
stability
what about lowering the alert status of
nuclear systems is is that a live option
or is that also politically infeasible
so that's that's also a message that's
connected to the first one which is
basically another way to kind of reduce
the risk of nuclear
weapon news is that Estates have a lower
dialect status so what what do we mean
by uh alet series is like basically how
ready you are to launch a nuclear weapon
and the lowest level possible is
basically where you know the the nuclear
weapons
um actual nuclear heads and the delivery
vehicles are kept separately and some
states do that
um like India Pakistan and China so like
even in order to have a loan first you
need to kind of put together
uh the nuclear heads and the delivery
like an Ethics takes time
so that's that's one way of of
providing yeah very critical time to
kind of mitigate the risk of the nuclear
nuclear war in a crisis or in in a in a
conflict
um
States the United States and Russia are
have are not true that have systems on
high alert means that they can basically
launch and nuclear attack very very
quickly uh but yeah again I think the
the
possibility right now that that state
would would um
decide to kind of lower the ls status
um it's pretty I mean it would certainly
be helpful for new reducing nuclear risk
um but it's it's unfortunately
unlikely in the current political
context
yeah so one thing that might be more
politically feasible is the option of
sharing information between experts and
being transparent about how uh how
you're incorporating AI in your nuclear
weapon systems and how optimistic are
you that this would make a real
difference
yeah so just about just
explain why it's helpful I think as as
we discussed before one of um one of the
challenge when we talk about the eye is
the idea that it's sunny
it's an intangible technology and it may
be hard for both sides to kind of
understand each other's capabilities in
that area
it's not like with things when you can
count you know the number of things that
they have or the number of like missiles
or like missile silos and everything uh
or you know that okay there are five
submarines and we have you know we have
two
um in the eye context it's much much
harder to kind of determine capabilities
so in that context the lack of knowledge
can be a source of insecurity uh where
States might take decisions based on
just guesses or like even advise
information so
really transparency on what the systems
are doing in the AI space could arguably
have a stabilizing effect
um and so that could be one one risk
reduction measures where uh States would
voluntarily
share some information with one another
about what they do in the AI space
obviously you know that would be very
high level and generic but that should
be enough to kind of at least engage
your conversation
um so that they have yeah some general
sense of what the others are doing or
not and it can also provide an Avenue
for them also discussing more uh
political elements like
Norms around responsible behavior in
terms of responsible use of some
some some of these Technologies how they
would solve some very practical problem
like okay how do we manage escalation in
a context where people deploy autonomous
online systems in a
how do we ensure that it doesn't lead to
escalation also so that could be the
basis then for more kind of like
collaborative risk production measures
in a sense but the first step would be
to kind of share information and again
that could also be
a useful method for
increasing common understanding creating
a common vocabulary a common
understanding of some of the technical
challenges or risk so
yeah so maybe this information
information sharing could start with
academics and experts and from there
maybe con various countries would be
able to build trust and then move on to
Infamous information sharing between
militaries is that possible do you think
yeah I mean in terms of like if we talk
about you know ways to
triple dialogue between nuclear arm
States obviously like
the most feasible is to start at a more
you know expert level uh so where
technical level
um where you have you invite either yeah
I expect to talk to with one another
around I don't know very kind of typical
AI problems like explainability of AI or
things like that
um or you invite
scholars in that work with extra
strategic studies or international
relations or to talk about some you know
things related to kind of impact on
tragic stability for instance or nuclear
risks or nuclear you know risk reduction
and
um escalation control and so on so this
is another so like that's most likely
that would be the the most feasible
Avenue
and then from there you can generate
input that then can fit into more kind
of official dialogues between states so
you could you could also have meetings
that are a bit of a mix where you have
academics and
experts and also some governmental
officials them also kind of engage in
some shape or form uh and then obviously
like under her at a more High political
level you can have direct
military to military contacts
and even us and Adam Ohio political
level what states would agree on zombie
that's all kind of risk production
measures or make some political
commitment toward one another around
um yeah so like in form of like
exchanging information or having some
form of a hotline to discuss some things
and this seems politically realistic to
you
I guess the what is in the current
political context I'll be honest I think
what is real this stick is is more to
kind of this kind of like expert
discussion
um all I'm saying that mainly because I
know that some of these type of
discussion exist and they have been
going on for a few years now where
they are they are we talk really about
the kind of expert level
um but there have been discussion
involving Chinese expert U.S expert
Russian experts European experts uh in
some small workshops or academic
conferences
we did some workshops like this
ourselves in the context of our project
where invited academics from
um we had the series original Workshop
around the globe and we invited people
like representative for more nuclear arm
States
um so these These are durable then the
question is like to what extent the
output from these meetings can actually
fit into more kind of
political
um substance it's obviously like your
geopolitical context is difficult
but let's hope that that at least
generates some useful information that
can be picked up at a little stage yeah
it definitely seems worth doing Vincent
uh thank you for coming on the podcast
thank you for sharing this valuable
information with us
thank you and just to to conclude I was
just on the line that uh the work that
I've been referring to and that the
provided the basis for for this
interview is is a collaborative exercise
I worked with
the report with a few other colleagues a
true international team Laura Salman
from the US Sue Faith China
from Russia and what happened from
Sweden so we it's a collective exercise
I want to acknowledge also the fact that
it's it's not just my research it's we
we did that together yeah noted thank
you thank you so much again for the
invitation